[Applause]
you
you
eating's [ __ ] uncle Joey here
it's a beautiful Monday it's a beautiful
day love to be alive but the most
important thing is God gave you another
day to slay mother [ __ ] dick and take
these [ __ ] Gentiles to the hoop jack
uncle Joey here [ __ ] category we're
back from Austin I'm rested and I'm
Monday you know me I'm the man of many
reefers Godzilla critical mass in this
shitty Jew it never ends we're gonna
start the week off with a good foot I'm
here today tomorrow and then Wednesday
Thursday [ __ ] front we're here before
King Day we all of New York City Friday
and Saturday Gotham comedy club open
closed the [ __ ] window if you're not
showing your [ __ ] slipping we don't
give a [ __ ] about bombs I'm saying we
don't give a [ __ ] about bombs we walk
around New York City [ __ ] with
regular clothes on with our chin up our
dick I'm ready to stab my family
it's a beautiful day to be alive these
pipes clean this [ __ ] today
jiu-jitsu I got a couple of [ __ ]
meetings I gotta catch some air beatings
from a few [ __ ] you know lying
to me you know how they are but I don't
give a [ __ ] I go I listen and I come
home to my family we got a church or
what's happening now tonight's eight
o'clock like a [ __ ]
Austin was [ __ ] great we taste about
Texas man it's a great [ __ ] state I
don't give a [ __ ] where you go you know
why because of people are silent like
[ __ ] them even the gay people don't have
attitude in Texas you talk to them
they're [ __ ] Cowboys there's
something they don't give a [ __ ]
everybody's cold [ __ ] Texas I love
that state I want to send out my heart
to Austin Texas I'll be back in Texas
the beautiful state of Texas November
18th in Houston
like the [ __ ] festival of love but
[ __ ] all that nonsense right now we're
talking about Monday [ __ ] Monday is the
main day and your [ __ ] life you
understand because you got to come out
of the [ __ ] box with a machine gun a
bazooka [ __ ] the [ __ ] zoo state of
mind see Jews are magicians they can
play [ __ ] confusion they you pay them
not to be [ __ ] confused Jim Sam the
first magician was Jesus they killed him
possess what they could do [ __ ]
better
but listen today I'm gonna meet with my
first [ __ ] real Jew attorney here and
now my Wayne [ __ ] around no more
I'm sick and tired of these people
showing up like johnny-come-lately with
the envelope a little [ __ ] light
would take I tell who I have a couple
[ __ ] good years left to me I might
not walk around [ __ ] I get with
people you follow me but besides that
it's all about the reefer today
yesterday before I [ __ ] stop with Lee
when we got off the plane I pick this
[ __ ] up
just [ __ ] cultivate it you understand
me
I got it nice and dry oh this is killing
I got a batch of this on its way to New
York City right now for the weekend
ignite that's that's how good that
reefer is people gonna be walking around
like [ __ ] the walking dead they smoke
this [ __ ]
nice nice and smooth goes right to the
[ __ ] brain I'm saying he makes you
[ __ ] paint real quick I don't know
what is does it [ __ ] matter it's dead
well Joey what's the percentage of THC
in it I don't know [ __ ] that don't
ask who gives a [ __ ] those questions of
the [ __ ] jack box
well I tell you it's [ __ ] that it's
debt I see is the way to start off a
Monday everybody wants to have a [ __ ]
kale shake with [ __ ] green lemon
juice and [ __ ] this is my kale [ __ ] the
kala [ __ ] debt this [ __ ]
saved life was kale Dunlevy
get your [ __ ] together reefer say little
eyes [ __ ]
I don't 10 people didn't smoke reefer
they'd be in jail for [ __ ]
manslaughter right now and guess what
cuz every day but it's all about love
today it's Monday don't let hate going
in my love love love and the day turns
out [ __ ] beautiful I gotta tell you
this one's halfway out he's playing a
half a [ __ ] play the Sun but you know
what I don't need the [ __ ] Sun why
cuz we got the Sun and I'm not sex
shining on [ __ ] that's right
one more [ __ ] bone we're taking this
to the hoop oh yeah that's how we
[ __ ] do it on a Monday morning and
it's 8:00 in the morning where the rest
of these [ __ ] ham superstars in their
house [ __ ]
playing a guide that nobody finds out
how much of a [ __ ] mutt they are but
his yong-chol Joey with you front inside
of hate there in the [ __ ] morning out
here banging it out you think I give a
[ __ ] about the neighbors think it all
suck my dick
it's you and me to the [ __ ] wheels
fall off the end there's the we Pablo
Escobar smoke when he blew up the
[ __ ] Oh Joe is wedding versus this
[ __ ] right here buddy it's on its way to
New York I got two Z's right now and
[ __ ] root on the mute if one don't
get there the other one will
we're picking up stars today it's gonna
be a good week instead it's gonna be a
good week mobility class my back feels
better my wrist is [ __ ] up but listen
we gotta had some blood that
[ __ ] why lay around sitting on
my wrist hurts who gives a [ __ ]
[Music]
alright this time that we spent together
in the Midlands understand mean there's
not my smoking reefer with [ __ ]
family because that's what we are family
if it wasn't for you [ __ ] that
wouldn't be that's why I do this on a
Monday morning to remind you about your
goals remind you to God who gives a [ __ ]
what they take a look at my face if I
gave a [ __ ] what they think I'd be
hidden in the [ __ ] cave right now I
don't give a [ __ ] with nobody thinks
because at the end of the day they got
all sucking dicks understand me it's
Monday you got a dream today as
[ __ ] starts if nobody's on
board flop them - that's my [ __ ] will
[ __ ] them - [ __ ] them all even Chino XL
[ __ ] them - it's your world
[ __ ] it's Monday today isn't
[ __ ] that the today isn't [ __ ]
careers and lives decision a t-t-tech
don't watch it - [ __ ] it stupid but you
can [ __ ] it all up and at the end you
[ __ ]
nice that you guys were a good little
[ __ ] audience I'm gonna move for
another book call the boss down ten more
minutes you smoking with yong-chol
chubby who gives a [ __ ] if he wants to
fire you were looking for a job when you
found that with [ __ ]
you know it's Monday we gotta get our
heads together people got blown up on
[ __ ] Saturday night
we got a few and go back in there see
how the [ __ ] we can stop this [ __ ] oh
yeah you know these [ __ ]
everybody's gotta save the [ __ ] world
nobody's got Walsall around to the
[ __ ] store I smack my [ __ ]
about stopping jump
now you see
this comes everything down you have to
talk the police breathing you take out
the dead [ __ ] now and that's it you
start the day off with a [ __ ] bang
okay I'll see you [ __ ] tonight
eight o'clock the church or what's
happened I don't show up if you ain't
bring both [ __ ] guns to like this we
ain't [ __ ] around alright I love your
[ __ ] I'll see you tomorrow I'll
forget you don't need no prescription
medication this will take away the
voices it works for me [ __ ] I see
is Friday and Saturday I have to Gotham
comedy club all right stay black
Timmy Holloway aka Marblehead get ready
to [ __ ] rock this weekend we're doing
everything for sugar the pills we're
jumping up and down method a method ado
or and company [ __ ] stick work